My guest this week has been described
as one of the greatest English
soccer strikers of all time.
As a player, Gary Lineker
scored 48 goals for England
and nearly 250 for English clubs.
Since leaving the pitch,
he's become the face of football
coverage here in the UK,
and is a big vocal
presence on social media.
When I sat down with him
ahead of the World Cup,
I wanted to ask him about concerns
to do with Qatar's human rights record,
the likes of David Beckham
doing deals with the state,
and why footballers can never win.
Gary, thank you so much for being here.
Pleasure.
Lovely to have you.
Thank you.
And it's an interesting
time to talk to you
because normally for a World Cup,
there'd be a lot of the usual feelings,
excitement, trepidation.
This feels quite different
because of the controversy
around where it is.
Believe you me, this is the
same before every World Cup.
There are different levels of
it, and this is high level,
but you can go back to 1934 if you want,
when the World Cup was in Italy.
It was used as a vehicle to
promote fascism for Mussolini.
So, this is not new.
Brazil in 2014, there
were riots on the streets
by people in Brazil saying
they shouldn't spend all
this money on the stadiums,
they should spend it on social care.
We had Russia who invaded Crimea
just a few years before
they hosted the World Cup.
So, it is not something
we're unaccustomed to.
Do you think it's on a
different scale though?
Because some of the reports, of course,
about the number of
lives that have been lost
in the building of the
stadium and the preparations?
I think what makes this different
is not just in terms of human rights
and obviously workers' rights
and what happened to them.
And lots of lives were lost
in the building of stadium.
I think what is really
different about this one
is that we know when the bid
was proved to be successful
that it was corrupt.
So I think that's what perhaps
separates this from the rest.
Human rights wise,
well there's a few countries
that have hosted it
that would fail some tests on that.
Yeah, well let's go to that in a minute.
But on the FIFA point,
because the former FIFA
president, Sepp Blatter,
has now said it was a mistake.
He waited a long time
to do that, hasn't he?
Yeah, I mean, not in the clearest-
I could have told him that
the minute he opened the
thing and it said Qatar on it.
I mean, do you think there's any value
in that statement at this point,
or is it just pointless to hear it?
I just don't understand
why he would do that now.
I dunno whether that
helps or hinders or what.
I mean he's the ex president of FIFA
at a time where there was
a lot of dodgy goings on.
So, yes, it was a mistake,
but it was more than a
mistake, wasn't it really?
Well, I mean also FIFA just
having put out this email,
let's not focus on the politics,
let's focus on the football.
Do you think FIFA has learned as a body
about what's the important focus?
I do believe that the current...
Maybe I'm being naive,
but I do believe the current
people in charge of FIFA
and it includes Arsène Wenger,
he's in a really high role.
I have certain amount of faith and trust
that Arsène Wenger is a decent,
upstanding, non-corrupt person.
I don't think the levels of
corruption, if there are any,
there will be in certain branches of FIFA
'cause it's global, but
in terms of the very top,
I think it's much more transparent.
The voting system is much more transparent
and there's less corruption.
Do they still make mistakes?
Yes, they do, in terms
of things that they say.
The thing you just mentioned
was very tone deaf to say that
because there's no question
that this is kind of sports washing,
but the reason sports washing works
is when you are told to shut
up about everything else
and just say, well just
stick to the football.
So I think that was an error
and I think it was a tone deaf statement.
And I think it's something
that most of the federations
will probably argue against.
Some of the players we've heard
might be wearing arm bands
in support of LGBTQ players
and people around the world.
Do you think we should hear more
from the players themselves?
Well, I think it's really
interesting, isn't it?
Because the minute players stand up
and voice their concerns,
everyone tells them, "Stay outta politics.
Stick to football."
Yeah.
When they don't stand
up and say something,
people say, "Why aren't
you saying anything?"
So there's an element of the footballers
that can't win on this.
They're inextricably linked,
politics and sport, all sport.
There's no getting away from that fact.
Politicians will use
football when it suits them.
So if England start doing well
and say they get to the
quarter finals or semifinal,
we'll all have our politicians standing up
and they'll be putting England jerseys on
and pretending to be really interested.
Now, some of them are
interested in football.
A lot of them aren't.
But even the ones that aren't
will suddenly be wanting to be seen
and jump on this England
bandwagon of success.
But the minute footballers
voice themselves
or come out and talk about social issues,
take Marcus Rashford for example,
take the captains during Covid,
all of a sudden it's like,
whoa, hang on a minute.
You're getting a bit
above your station here.
So footballers are allowed to speak
when it suits the
politicians, I always feel.
It's always been a little bit
of a kind of pet hate of mine.
Of course though,
the people they answer to
are their fans, as well.
So yes, the politicians
make the statements
and get the air time in response,
but I suppose it's just also,
it's been striking how
some of the female players
have spoken out, female
football players, about it.
I was looking at the comments
from England's Lotte Wubben-Moy
who said she's not going to watch it.
Beth Mead, of course, is a
hugely successful striker.
She's done so well in the game.
She's just winning all these
accolades. She's gay herself.
She's said, "It's just so disappointing."
But it's quite a big thing to
say you're not gonna watch it
when you play football for a living.
Yeah, yeah.
But I mean, people make
their own decisions
on what they have to do.
I just wondered, do you
think they're being bolder
'cause they're not involved or-
Of course they are, yeah.
I mean, it's very easy to say these things
if you're not gonna play in it.
It's a different thing.
Do you think footballers get
scared about speaking out
or get nervous?
I think some will, some won't.
Some are brave, some have stand out.
I've been really proud of footballers
over the last few years.
I think they've really
come out on social issues.
I've mentioned Rashford before.
The captains during the thing.
We've seen people like Raheem Sterling
speak out brilliantly on
racism and things like that.
So I've been really proud of the fact
and a lot of them do
and a lot of them will.
Others are less comfortable
and for me, it's purely a personal issue.
You know, if somebody
wants to take a stand
in a certain way, that's fine.
And if somebody just wants
to concentrate on their game
and possibly their only
opportunity to play in a World Cup
and they just wanna get on
with the football side of it
and not let these things
creep in, that's fine too.
You've talked a bit about,
because just to say very clearly,
homosexuality is illegal in Qatar.
There are also other issues
that are very different
culturally for the fans,
perhaps we'll come on to,
but you've also talked
about it would be a moment,
not to put pressure, but it
would be a bit of a moment
if a footballer came out as gay-
Well, it could-
During this time.
I did say that, but I didn't
say a footballer should.
No, no, no, which is why
I was making that-
The context is important.
So, I was saying it would be, you know,
a big kind of middle finger
to perhaps that thing.
And it won't happen.
I wouldn't put pressure on any player
ever to do that anyway.
But of course, it's an issue,
the human rights side of things.
It has to be.
The Qatar World Cup ambassador
has just called homosexuality
damage in the mind.
I saw that.
Which is an insight into the view,
the reason for the view.
If you were gay, as a fan,
would you go to this tournament?
It's a great question.
I don't know because it's
a hypothetical question.
You would have to give it
a lot of thought, I think.
You know, I saw one of
their main representatives,
I think it was Al Thani,
speaking in an interview
saying that, you know, gay
people will be welcome.
The question was asked,
"What about if they walked
down the street holding hands?"
He said, "That would be absolutely fine."
But let's see.
But there's a risk though.
But there's a risk.
But I understand why people...
If the LGBTQ, et cetera,
would have reservations
and thoughts and concerns.
Absolutely.
Whether I, you could say,
whether I would go if I were gay,
I honestly don't know.
I don't know.
I mean you obviously you
are going to work to-
I'm going to work, yeah. Yeah.
How you feeling about that with this-
No, I'm fine
but I don't have the slightest
problem about going to work.
I'm not going there to support
the World Cup being in Qatar.
I'm going there to report it.
Yeah, it's a common sense.
For me, that's my job
as a kind of sports
broadcaster, journalist.
You know, journalists
will be sent to the war
with Russia and Ukraine.
But it doesn't mean, say,
they support what's going on.
No, no, no, and I didn't mean that,
but I meant more like if
there was any nervousness,
you know, just things like
Qatar's UK ambassadors
warned against public
displays of affection.
I'm not saying you're gonna to be
doing any affection with your colleagues.
Chance should be a fine thing.
Happily single man, I understand.
But also, for the fans,
I wonder if you've got a
nervousness about that,
not just on the human rights side,
but the zero tolerance
for drinking in public and being drunk.
I know.
Well, I always have concerns
about English fans traveling abroad
because I'm afraid a
small percentage of them
do go there looking for trouble,
looking to just get drunk,
looking for a fight.
And that's been part of something,
it's been detestable around
the England squad for years
and they ruin it for everyone else.
What will happen to them in Qatar,
I don't know if they go along that things,
but I think we've all got-
Well, I think all football fans obviously
in their ranks have the
drinking side of things.
Yeah, the drink, well yes.
It's a nervousness perhaps
around the whole thing as well.
Yeah, I'm sure. I'm sure.
I mean, I think we'll all
be thinking ourselves, how
do we get a drink at some point.
There might be that, as well.
Many footballers, as
yourself, become pundits,
ambassadors, journalists, commentators.
There has also been
criticism of, for instance,
David Beckham becoming a
paid ambassador to Qatar,
headed to the World Cup.
He's got to promote tourism
and culture in Qatar.
He's become the face of it.
What do you make of that sort of decision?
Well that's, again, it's
a personal decision.
I'm not gonna sit here and be judgemental.
Would I do it? No.
Eric Cantona, who
obviously played with him,
has spoken out and urged
him to think differently.
Yeah, and I understand why he's done that.
And as I said, would I have done it? No.
He's decided to go down that route.
I would say about David,
he's never really voiced his concerns
about where the World Cup is.
So, you know, it's not something
he's ever got involved in.
So, can you accuse him,
but he's not hypocritical.
If I'd have done it, I was
very, very anti the bid
when it was first revealed in 2010.
I was in the room. I couldn't believe it.
It seemed to me that it
must have been corrupt
because they were talking about
staging a summer World Cup in Qatar
where temperatures are in the 40s,
sometimes even approaching
50 degrees centigrade.
It seemed unfathomable.
Then, obviously, laterally
it was moved to winter
and I was very vocal against it.
So if I was gonna do something like that,
I'd feel hypocritical.
I don't think you could
accuse Beckham of that.
You might accuse him of doing something
that you might feel is
fundamentally a wrong thing to do.
And a lot of people will think that.
Are you disappointed by
him doing that though?
'Cause he's a role model
for a lot of people.
And has been.
He is a role model.
As I said, I wouldn't do it.
I think also people will think,
why does he need 10 million quid?
Does he really need to do that?
That's the other question
when they don't get-
I mean, I have no idea how
much he's getting paid,
but I suspect-
Has he reported?
I suspect he would survive without it.
I suppose it's that, you
know, the feeling of influence
and how people have influence
and what they use it for.
Of course, you know, football is a...
Obviously, sport's a massive thing
around the whole world anyway,
and football in particular,
and just before a World Cup, it is.
And there's a lot of
expectancy on footballers,
but you know, there's a lot of criticism
about how much they earn
and stuff like that.
And footballers do get it in the neck.
It's like, it's tough to win.
Obviously they have a
wonderfully lucrative life,
but it's funny, I always think
they don't really get the
criticism in other people,
in other sports, even.
Like, you know, you got lots of money,
like golf or Formula One
or you could even go in
other routes, like actors.
Huge actors earn fortunes.
Musicians, brilliant musicians.
If you're in the entertainment industry,
you do get paid a lot of money,
but no one else gets that football,
it's almost as though, all
these are working class lads.
It's a little bit different.
Is that what you think is going on?
I genuinely believe it
might be subconsciously,
but I think there's an element of that.
They're a bit above their station.
Is it also because they can and do,
especially 'cause they're so
young earning so much money,
get into a lot of trouble at times?
Like the drunk-
Well, not many of them do.
Not many of them do.
And the other thing is-
Is that a perception thing?
It is absolutely a perception thing.
Footballers are a cross section
of working class society really.
They come up and it's hard.
They have to work really hard.
They live very well.
Like every now and again, a
footballer will misbehave,
one out of, you know, there
are thousands of them around,
but that becomes a huge story.
All the incredible good that they do
for like local communities,
visiting kids in hospital,
doing loads of good things,
raising awareness of whether it be racism
or during the Covid pandemic,
that doesn't become the big story,
but, you know, one player goes
out in a drunken night out
and gets pictured with
a girl or something,
then that becomes like a front page story.
And it's a little bit unfair
and that doesn't really
happen as much in other areas.
See, it's a disproportionate-
I think it's disproportionate, yeah.
I mean of course when actors, you know,
behave badly or things,
it also gets captured,
but it's interesting to hear
you think it is disproportionate.
I mean, we should also say
there have been some
really high profile cases
and allegations made against
top class footballers
in relation to behavior with women.
On the surface, it seems
a change in the culture
when you were playing around the game.
I don't know if that's fair
and what you think around that.
I don't know.
I still think, when I played,
I doubt it's that much different now.
You'd have-
It's a lot more money I suppose-
Well there is a lot-
People not settling down.
There is a lot more money
and there'd be a lot
more, you know, dangers
and outside interests.
I honestly think that mostly though,
like the massive majority of footballers
have been really good lads, well behaved,
work really, really hard on
what they do and live properly
because you have to now
because it's so competitive.
And I think it was exactly
the same in my day.
You will still get the
odd drunk, the odd sexist,
the odd homophobic person,
like a cross section of
working class society,
and the odd person that
will commit a crime.
But it's not rife, you know.
It's very occasional and limited.
I'm not trying to defend
the actions of the few.
No, no, no.
I could hear that.
You tried to put it in context.
I'm trying to get a
context and perspective
of the overall picture of footballers.
I suppose though, the other
thing that's undeniable
is we still don't have an
openly gay male footballer
in the Premier League.
What could change or how could
that change do you think,
to make that a space where
it feels comfortable?
I don't know.
I mean, it is distressing
and we're starting to see it
in other sports, aren't we,
you know, Tom Daley we've seen...
Well in the women's game as well.
In the women's game, as well.
I just would love it if
we had an environment
where they just felt they should...
It seems absurd that anyone should-
'Cause often when you
talk about society-
Be scared
to say who you are.
It can be true.
It's a society thing,
as well.
I mean, I kind of probably naively
said something in an interview recently
that got picked up by quite
a few smart gay people,
which I've kind of learned from.
I was saying, I honestly think
that if a footballer came out
it would be hugely positive
and others would follow.
I was kind of told, you know,
you have no idea how
difficult this situation is.
So, I mean it's delicate and it's true.
It's kind of baffling
because it's obvious there must be
lots of Premier League footballers
and footballers around
the country that are gay
and are having to live
and not be their true selves.
And I think that's really sad.
Did you, like, looking
back on your career,
do you think you played alongside men
who weren't their true selves in that way?
Oh yeah, I think so. I think so.
I'm pretty sure. I don't know
for a fact, but I think so.
Do you have young footballers
who come to you to say-
I've had a couple, both
anonymous actually.
One was very close to coming out.
He was actually the secret gay footballer
and I was talking to him on
direct message quite a lot
and I was gonna be doing the interview,
but then he got cold
feet at the last second
and I said, "Well I totally respect that.
I totally understand."
And then I was reached
out through my agency,
another anonymous footballer
who was thinking about it.
So I don't know who they
are, but they're out there.
Of course they're out there.
And I couldn't understand
how incredibly difficult it must be for-
Do you think it's the fans mainly?
I don't know. I don't know.
It's probably everything, you know.
Who knows, they might not
have told their family.
They might be scared about that.
They might be scared about
telling their teammates
in the dressing room.
It must be quite,
incredibly difficult. Tough.
On your coming out with
your political views,
a different type of coming out,
and saying more what
you think about things,
it actually did take you
a long time, didn't it?
It took social media.
Is that what it was?
I mean, I've always had to, you know-
No, no.
I had nowhere to share them.
And I think, you know, when
you speak out like that,
there are people who
don't like the reactions
and have ended up then self-censoring.
Do you ever have that fear,
that anxiety after you've sent a post or?
I have a policy with...
I've got three rules in Twitter.
One is not to tweet when
I'm, had a few drinks,
which I stick to.
The other is not to tweet if I'm angry,
but I don't really get angry.
But, you know, when I'm too frustrated.
And my other one is that
whenever I do any kind of tweet,
I'll read it back and
then if I have 1% doubt,
I won't send it.
It's gone.
Although that one, occasionally,
when I think of something
that I think actually that's quite funny,
I'll take a chance.
But generally they are my three rules.
Would you pay for your authentication-
I wouldn't have paid-
for your blue tick?
$44 billion for Twitter.
That was a slightly separate deal.
Well, I never asked for
it in the first place, so.
No, no, but the whole idea
of how they're gonna
change the model, pay-
Yeah, I don't know yet.
I'm gonna weigh it up.
I'm not gonna make any rash decision now.
I mean, you know, it's not...
But the truth is actually,
I mean a lot of people are on Twitter
to follow people that
they find interesting,
mostly blue tick people,
whether they're like a politician or actor
or a sports person or a
musician or real comedians,
and you follow them and
they're the blue tick ones.
So actually I think it's
the blue tick people
that entice more people onto the platform.
So Elon Musk, I think should
be paying us $8 a month,
everyone on there, rather
than the other way round.
Well you can tweet him direct
'cause he replies it seems
to absolutely everyone.
Does he? Oh, right.
Especially if you've got a blue tick.
I doubt he'd agree with me though.
I dare you to tweet him.
You mentioned, of course,
the reaction to footballers,
former footballers like yourself,
from politicians at times
and you brought up the pandemic, as well.
And here in the UK,
the former health secretary, Matt Hancock,
when asked about footballer's
wages during the lockdown,
during the pandemic, said quote,
"Everybody needs to play their
part in this national effort,
and that means Premier
League footballers, too."
He talked about taking pay
cuts. You'll remember all this.
He's now in Australia taking
part in a reality TV show
called "I'm a Celebrity,
Get Me Out of Here."
Been suspended as a Conservative MP.
Do you think he's playing
his part as an MP?
I think he should have stuck
to telling footballers
to stick to football.
Yes.
I mean, do what he wants,
but he's still an acting politician,
so it seems a bit strange to me
to disappear into the jungle.
I think maybe...
Did you see that thing when
Rishi Sunak was welcomed
and he shook everyone's hand
and he kind of ignored
Hancock in the middle?
Yes.
Maybe that maybe him go-
That was it.
That was it. I'm going to bloody jungle.
It might also be the $400 grand
that he's been rumored to be-
That might be one of the
400,000 reasons for him going.
We don't know.
I dunno
if he's getting that,
but they do pay well apparently.
Apparently so.
But I suppose it was what you
were talking about earlier
about who stays in which
lane and who polices who.
Well, of course.
And with politicians, I
always find it depends,
that they'll do it when it suits them.
Yes.
Well, and then, and then of course
there are those who feel,
you know, very passionately
our politicians shouldn't be celebrities
and shouldn't be reaching for that
'cause they're public servants.
And then there's very serious
points about him going in,
I suppose, from those who were
bereaved during the pandemic
and feel-
Indeed.
I can understand people's
reservations about it.
It's almost a kind of bit of
comedy in a way, isn't it?
But there are obviously
more serious issues
that he was a large part of the early days
with, you know, so many deaths in Covid.
Some would throw the
blame at the government
in terms of the lack of protection,
certainly in care homes
and things like that.
So, I dunno.
I mean, I dunno whether
I'll even watch it.
So, you've not been tempted
to do any of those
particular shows yourself.
Good Lord, No.
If you ever see me in one of those,
you'll know things have
gone horribly wrong.
We know it's really bad.
That's your equivalent
of taking some of these
other deals perhaps.
Yeah, I think that'd be even worse.
I dunno. No, it'd be my worst night.
Thank you so much for talking to me.
Pleasure.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.